corey malone coming on the show that's
right
hi corey how you doing thanks for coming
on the program thanks for inviting me
this podcast first podcast ever for you
ever
hell yeah so this is nice boom popping
the cherry popping the podcast
podcast sherry yeah especially because
it's
a podcast so focused on the nature of
reality
and that's what you so dearly care about
so it makes
sense of course yeah and we've been
connecting for
past couple days on that subject uh
and it's been very flowy and natural
yeah for sure yeah
yeah and we're of course still at the
shift into permanent
alignment retreat of bentinum
sorrows here in costa rica and we
are vibing
at a really strong level between us and
between several of the other attendees
around the nature the true nature
this abiding as
which many people recognize as just
awareness which is again juxtaposed with
the transient
clouds and thoughts and perceptions and
sensations so
most people get to that level of at
least being awareness
and then even further beyond that is
making that
impersonal making that eternal making
that shared among us
that is infinitely colored by all of
these worlds that we create
and then recognizing even the source
realization the void the infinite
realization
yes and that we've been vibing on that
so let's play some tennis and then also
i'll ask corey about some of the satori
as well which has been
really exciting to go back and forth on
so
how has it been like for you recognizing
the impersonal witnessing
so we'll i guess even be getting into
some of the satori here as well how has
it been like for you getting into
that juxtaposition between those
transient clouds and the awareness
and then making that impersonal and then
recognizing that source
void infinite yeah absolutely great
awesome question
um for me the easiest
thing was kind of
how bentino says um focus on awareness
that has been the easiest thing to do
because
you just become aware and then at first
when you first start it's it's
you don't really grasp it you don't
really get it
it doesn't really land but you keep
going and keep okay awareness
oh i am aware i'm aware
somehow i'm aware okay and then you
you take that even further and go
oh i'm aware that i'm aware and then
that pushes you back
and then you see the clouds yes so for
me
that awareness of awareness gives you
that pushback
that view that broad broader spectrum
of um of that seeing the clouds and
abiding
as a awareness itself yes yeah
so that helped me begin with when did
you become
aware of awareness when was that for you
when was that transition for you
um it happened in kind of
baby steps yes yes it i i'm not really
the type to sit down and meditate
i'm more of an active meditator totally
go out for a long walk
um just sit here and contemplate um so
it'll be just like a moment aware of
awareness
oh yeah oh cool that was cool so it's
not like
i'm aware of awareness and i'm there
permanently now
it's a lot of those i mean i can access
it now yes
yes um but it's just a lot of those
doing it for a second for a second
for a second yeah so maybe about two
years ago is when i was like
oh because it's so liberating and you
feel your
whole body relaxed and you feel your
experience just relaxed
what about you so great so that was
about two years ago or so i would say
about two years we
have to share this right now look at
this
oh my gosh this is so cute we have some
friends
wow maybe they'll speak on maybe they'll
speak on abiding
[Laughter]
wow look at these guys maybe they are
right now costa rica
little monkeys look at them look at them
looking at us wow
wow that looks so so so cool that's so
cool wow
i love that scene that's so great
that's so great but that's we got to
share that yeah i love it it's really
cool
yeah that was almost like perfect yeah
picture picturesque so
okay so about two years ago or so for me
yeah for you and
for me it's probably about four months
ago or so okay yeah about four months
ago
and very similar to what you
described very very similar and that's
basically the core
of the mystic traditions is to become
aware of awareness itself
okay and i really like the going back
that's something that also rumi and so
many others have talked about is kind of
the sinking back
and back and back more and more and more
and then you really gain that meta-level
perspective and then all these analogies
like the sky
and then the clouds appear and disappear
it's like so
easy it's easy it's childlike in
simplicity yes and then you just
recognize that more and more in
when you look up at the sky and then you
see
the clouds from moving and you recognize
that that's exactly what's up
so it's super important that's why
douglas hofstetter called
analogy the core of cognition so it's
the core
of cognition it's not just some little
area
of cognition it's literally the core
that's why when we use this
sky in clouds or the ocean and the waves
analogies
the reason why we use them is because
it's the core of cognition
it's what makes it the here's
enlightenment
and then here's the sky and the clouds
slash the ocean and the waves
we draw the comparison between the two
because it's the core of cognition yeah
right so it's already there as a
foundation yeah
yep that's really cool it's as above so
below mirrored
everywhere in existence yes
yes there you go awesome we as the
creators
make the as above so below it's like the
fractal kaleidoscopic
creativeness of our i like that yeah
of what we made yeah yeah absolutely i
like those words put together too that
was cool
yeah actually one of them yeah and one
of them actually came from
mr jb jordan bates who just walked in
he because what this is in many ways
is this is that fractal kaleidoscopic
mr jb you want to join it come come join
in say hello say what up yeah
say what up what's up everybody hey hey
there's a monkey right now
we showed them these in the video
already we were
it was already celebratory yes jordan
in our last episode that you guys have
probably seen mentioned kaleidoscope
right and that's very much what this
shirt is pointing to as well the
kaleidoscopic
fractal-ness the
yeah yeah and and so that's what like we
uh share here is that everything we see
is just like
the seer itself just like the source
itself it's
all that same patterned self-similarity
it's just a direct reflection it's a
direct reflection right now
right here absolutely or you can even go
with the sky here and these
examples right here exactly yep
yep and that's this is exactly what we
shared on the
show with jordan just a bit ago too yeah
we share this similar
visualization so it's um
okay so let's keep let's keep playing
with uh
so now
you you mentioned how as you get into
the
aware of awareness about two years ago
does it feel like then you're
extending the amount of time that you're
in that
state during the day
yes absolutely and then it you realize
more
timelessness as well yes you don't
really
feel that okay it's two o'clock now it's
three o'clock you don't feel that
one after another anymore you it's less
cause and effect
it's more now perfect so
which is really cool perfect once you
experience it it it
it makes life fun for me it makes life
beautiful it's a different experience
but it is
experiential before you experience it it
can be
conceptual it really won't make sense
yep yep
it sounds kind of crazy woo whatever
um and it has everything contained
within it has healing properties
you become more of yourself you become
more of service
yes you are able to flow you're able to
naturally do what you need to do and do
your passions so
it's uh it's it's there's no words
really
i love how you indicate that as you
abide more in the timeless presence the
timeless being
of pure bear empty awareness itself that
is shared in eternal among us
that time disappears along with ego
time disappears yeah those two things
are the two that disappear so that's
the egoic contracted separate entity
that needs to seek
happiness from substances and
experiences and
other selves yes that kind of thing
disappears it dissolves
absolutely and then also time dissolves
and when time dissolves you really
recognize that timeless presence and
being
and awareness that's shared internal and
then you abide as that more and more and
the realization sets in more and more
the true timelessness sets in more
and more yeah absolutely so you felt
timeless as yes
awesome yeah especially in these last
couple of months abiding more
is the key really abiding so for those
that are not
yet really at this abiding ass source or
void or infinity
to abide at least as awareness
itself start there start there start
just
being aware of something aware of this
water here where we're talking that's
good it helps
just to be aware of something and that's
really that's mindfulness
mindfulness exactly yeah so mindfulness
is we take
an object we have these you know these
sunglasses here
and we focus or on cory's shirt his pink
shirt here or on this fractal shirt
whatever and we take an object
and we just practice and this is what's
taught in theravada buddhism
buddhism a lot of the buddhist practices
especially in the mystic traditions even
across the
abrahamics basically what is taught is
is that to become aware of respiration
and then as you become aware of
respiration you also become aware of
concentration
at the same time because as soon as your
attention goes away from the respiration
from the breath
or from the object right when you're
looking at somebody else in the eyes
and if the moment that you follow one of
the clouds of thought to oh i have to go
to this important thing later today or
whatever
you lose eye contact with them you lose
your focus on them the concentration
you can tell energetically that the
conversational
energy decreases because you're not as
present there
absolutely and so that's why they use
the breath because the breath is the
tool that's always with you right
and if you have to you can use an object
like this but really the breath
is the main key and so as we get more
accustomed to the breath
what happens is we become more
accustomed to concentration and when we
become more constant to concentration
that's when we can recognize the
difference between the
thoughts and perceptions that are like
the clouds that appear and disappear
versus the awareness of the
consciousness the witnessing in which
they happen
so those are like the frames the frames
of the movie that go by
right and to be the one that's
witnessing the frames of the movie as
they go by
and then you abide as the witnessing and
that's a great first
step it is it is it's the first step
um mindfulness is wonderful
get familiar with that but don't stay
there
exactly don't stay there because it will
only take you so far
exactly and what you really want is to
be that aware of awareness
that's the easiest way for me to put it
yes so it's almost like
when i started the aware of awareness
practice
i would it would help to visualize like
almost here's awareness
and then i'm aware of this like my mind
would kind of
place something on top of something so
i'm aware of that so whatever works for
you yes you know
whatever work to help you hone in to
that aware of awareness
exactly yeah yep and ramdas's
i am loving awareness has been something
also really powerful and he and east
forest made a
a musical collab about that as well i
am loving awareness yes
and with the great music it's good to
leverage that also to abide in a sense
it's almost as though we can use
music which alan watts and so many
others have said
is very much like the nature of reality
is like the endless
music that is played yes and so to
recognize and david hawkins has talked
about it as your and we talked about
this yesterday
the surfing on the crest of every wave
yeah you want to surf on the crest of
every wave and not
fighting against the waves or like when
you see the
movie film that comes and then you fight
against the movie film you're like i
want a different
movie or like i don't [ __ ] that cloud i
want a different club
it's not the shape i like yeah
yeah this is a cloud you know but
going back to that which will relate is
how you said the ego
kind of dissipates yes when you practice
or abide in that aware of awareness
which is which is where that comes from
i don't like that cloud yeah i don't
like that thought i don't like what i
just saw i don't like where my life is
going okay
no it's going perfectly if you can swim
with that if you could kind of
smooth that out a little bit it's gonna
take a little time maybe maybe not
depends on what's going on but smooth
that out
surf a little bit go with the flow don't
swim
upstream yeah yeah you're already
the oceanicness that is endlessly
exploring
and yet there's also this is the whole
perfection perfecting thing that i think
is
going to be really crucial as we move
forward which is really what the tai chi
do in where you have the monist
perfection and then the yin yang inside
of it which is the perfecting
because here's the thing because you and
i both know this
five years ago right when we weren't
aware of awareness when we weren't
abiding as source infinity void when we
weren't doing that
what were we we were the egoic separate
contracted
energy yes okay so although that was
perfect
because it was going with the flow it
was also perfecting
in the sense of the purification of the
diamond
becoming less egoic and less dirty and
becoming more enlightened
yes absolutely and so that's the core
here is that as you also
you become at peace with the clouds or
with the waves that or with the
images that appear on the movie screen
but yet you also as the witness
recognize
that there is a constant bifurcations
that are happening
in your trajectory and that if you abide
more
as hey i'm going to take that
recommendation
from you know corey and atlas talking
about ram das or alan watts or bentino
or whoever
and i'm gonna pick up be here now by
ramdas and i'm gonna read that
yes right absolutely and so now see you
see that bifurcating moment where it's
like am i gonna be lazy
lethargic and not really care too much
because then there's just going to be
another sledgehammer that comes
you know that oh yeah because suffering
is the drill sergeant
or will you take it right and then
that's those bifurcations to perfect
the diamond cleanse it yeah absolutely
that's that's beautiful because it will
it will kick you punch you slap you into
alignment
depending on how far away you're uh
not wanting to to to go with the flow um
so that's really that's really beautiful
another thing that helped me as well
is um the follow the breadcrumb trail of
excitement
yeah i heard that from bashar yes a
while ago
and i've always loved that because
that's also your flow
totally so if you can do that if you can
go okay well
somebody invited me to go out tonight
what feels true not
what do i want to do what feels like ah
okay cool
or that sounds fun or something exciting
kid like
do that if it's stay home do that
because it'll help you like get used to
that flow
you know so maybe that'll help you get
used to that aware of awareness as well
yes and that's something that i like to
uh tell people as well because it's a
cool way to live
too yep you know because it's your
higher self going okay go that way do
this
take that sip of water do that do this
meet this person exactly go with the
flow and you get used to it and it's
like a muscle
and it becomes pretty natural yes so and
joseph campbell talks about it like
following your bliss
yes and then also the bentino talks
about it like
there's nothing more true about you than
the seeking impulse that's like
he calls it the absolute gps callback
right and and that's what's taught in
the parable of the prodigal son
yeah the sun ventures outward seeking
peace and happiness in maya in the
illusion yeah trying to extract it
and then it turns around because it hits
a breaking point with suffering to
investigate consciousness or awareness
itself that absolute gps callback
and so all of these the breadcrumb trail
that is that
that is that is that and so they're all
all these different teachings are just
different ways different pointings
different faces of the same mountain
different paths
to the one end as alan watts says many
paths
one end yes yes that is so cool
and that's why another reason why that's
a
beneficial way of following your
resonance is because everyone has a
different path
we talked about this last night as well
or yesterday i think the unique style
of finding yes at lunch we talked about
it
the unity of all finding everyone corey
is going to have his own unique
style of findings with his own paths his
own books his own meditations his own
aphorisms his own teachers
and then i have my own you have your own
etc exactly
and i love the all your terminology
you're using for all these mystic
terminology because i am not very
familiar with that
um it's something that may spark an
interest in me at some point but
it just goes to show that you can get to
the same point without
you don't need to learn the history you
don't need to learn this just follow
what feels right and that teacher will
pop up for you no matter if it's
if it looks that way or that way yep so
okay so now let's talk about yeah as
you've become
more and more used to abiding in
awareness itself
then you recognize that even that is
impersonal so that our awareness is
shared
the awareness of all eight billion units
on the planet is shared it's the same
observation that's happening
through all 8 billion perspectives yes
okay and then how has that process been
like in your
day-to-day right here you are sitting
here with me you're abiding as the
observation happening through
both of us simultaneously yeah okay
absolutely cool um yeah
you just abide in that awareness of
awareness and you become
more present yes to the moment you don't
have to practice presence
unless that works but you become more
present
and then like we talked about earlier
that timelessness
you feel that you experience that and at
the same
time you experience oneness
yes yes so right now i'm looking at you
yeah but i feel
one that's right it's not even
person-to-person oneness it's uh
it's just it's one it's a one
non-physical
spiritual existence
yeah a non-physical spiritual existence
a one god
self right yeah operating as one yeah
that's one yeah um yeah so i'm
okay so i'm not interested a little bit
on your awareness of awareness yes
so four months ago yes is your approach
more meditative sit down and meditate
read what is what is your approach to
read or or
yeah so or is it moment to moment like
yeah sonia and i were actually talking
about this today
as well so she asked about
my satori i asked hers about
i asked about hers yesterday and
probably the two core contributions
to satori for me
were over the last five years picking up
meditation
so specifically like theravada buddhism
mahayana buddhism
specifically like zokchen specifically
the other mindfulness and meditation
practices that basically what they do is
what we talked about earlier which is
that you become
aware of respiration and then you
basically over and over again like
you're at a gym doing repetitions or
you're practicing shooting
three-pointers
or you're practicing playing the violin
what you do is you train the monkey mind
to stop running rampantly with clouds
and instead you become aware of the
witnessing of those clouds
right so that was the first key thing is
sitting for these 10 straight days
over and over again to practice that and
then the second key thing so the first
keyword is meditation and the second key
word is polymathy
being a polymath which means having
learned much across many disciplines
so when you study science and you study
entrepreneurship
and you study spirituality across all
the mystic traditions all this type of
stuff
what you end up doing is you build up a
really robust lattice work
that then assists you in seeing the same
mountains
faces and paths to the one end
so you see all those different paths and
so they're all like concepts in the
lattice work science entrepreneurship
spirituality merge together
and then they all interplay on this so
then that led up to
the piercing of the veilless veil which
was
i yeah i cried and went into the fetal
position for like 15 minutes once i
realized the route
the it was that really
landed it for me it basically took me
away from
being focused on what was happening
externally
and i became permanently focused on
awareness and then i recognized that
everybody shares that
awareness and then everybody has their
own unique finding
right and then right when that hit that
clicked as i was reading through wadata
specifically william chidix explanation
of it from the ibn arabi society
and i i cried i went to the fetal
position for like 15 minutes because i
finally as the roomie quote goes you go
from room to room looking for the
diamond that's already around your neck
and i didn't know exactly it's so good
and i didn't know what he meant by it
you would read the quote
like a dozen times and over a couple of
years and you'd never
never get it and then i finally got it
and then i said the guy's goat
and so he's go greatest of all time for
that quote and beyond
but that was basically it and then since
then it's also been abiding
let's actually talk about this now
abiding as infinity source
void and so for you what has been the
recognition for you
as even the source realization or
infinity or void realization
that the first agent or the first
attribute
of that is awareness yes yeah so how has
that
been for you to recognize the the
awareness to begin with to recognize
that even awareness is an
attribute or an agent
to go even beyond that let's go beyond
okay good okay cool
so you get familiar with that aware of
awareness
and that pushes you back you see the
clouds you see your thoughts you see
your emotions all this stuff um
but there's there's more you can keep
going um
i would have to relate it to uh very
much
relate with ben tinia's work how he
talks about uh the god state and then
the absolute
yeah on a walk i i was i was thinking
about the absolute so i was abiding in
that awareness of awareness
i felt very aware and just very present
and very free
and then i just thought of what's beyond
that
and then just i can even see it in my
in in my mind's eye right now it's just
this big
there's no way to describe it but just a
void
yeah just avoid this big black
there's not even space it's just so
there and at first i was like
did i just glimpse the absolute no
but yes absolutely and then there and
then that's when you realize
nothing is even happening exactly
nothing's happening
there's not even this experience that's
right
yeah and um
really don't even know how to express it
further than that because there's no no
words
yep there's not a thought there's not a
word that can relate to that because the
thoughts the words are
here on this plane but absolute reality
the infinity infinite is
nothing yeah nothing nothing and
everything and everything
exactly absolute nothingness and
absolute
infinity at the same time at the same
time it's it's this in that
yes it's it's nothing at everything and
when i say nothing it's not a negative
thing
it's just it's not the experience that
you feel like you're having and that's
why the best way to describe it when you
say that it's hard to use words that we
found so far is the dream
so when you when you make a dream you
simulate a dream at night during
sleep you simulate the environment and
you simulate the observer
so you simulate the little cory that
goes into the dream that then
experiences the dream but then when you
wake up the next day
did the dream happen right there you go
that's the nothingness that we're
talking about
right yeah which it's also not to say
that this
isn't massively relevant it's massively
relevant and beautiful
and true and true and play and play but
that's the thing it makes it more fun it
makes it okay
this is more flowy this is more easy and
then you can
you know realize your purpose and that's
what the creator wants to express
through you
is that that individual purpose of why
am i here
and then you can answer those questions
so much easier and so much more of a
play
kind of sense to it um yeah so what
about you for this absolute infinity
very much similar to where you're
playing with it i love that so much it's
like and as we've talked about several
times throughout
keep going keep going when you get past
the thought clouds
and get to the observation state the
awareness state
keep going because then you go from your
localized your personalized awareness
to the impersonal awareness to the
shared eternal awareness to corey's
awareness
being the same awareness that this atlas
is awareness
the same awareness that's coming through
you guys and then you begin holding that
sort of macro level god state
consciousness that incorporates all of
these little perspectives at the same
time
and then you become that right so that's
one layer back and then now
as bentino has been using this really
good way of understanding it
which is you basically pluck the last
thorn which is awareness the shared and
personal awareness
out and then that's what the absolute
devoid the infinite realization
is yes there's it's agentless and it's
attributeless yes those are the two
best words to describe it agentless and
attributeless
and also absolute nothing and
absolute infinity at the same time and
that's what's meant by enlightenment
the no self and the all self
at the same time so that's how i've been
basically now the game is abiding as the
title of the episode
you basically you abide as awareness
first yeah step one
abide as infinity second step two yes
and that's the game
that's that's the game right yes
absolutely and and and a good way of
looking at it is a kind of a spectrum
yes it's not uh oh i invited infinity
and then that's
it yeah life is good yeah yeah yeah
great man
you know i you know i thought that too i
was like okay
it's like a destination once i get there
what's gonna happen am i gonna change no
no no it's just
just what we're talking about you just
end up more flowy
your life becomes more you know
efficient in a
in a positive way um but yeah wrestling
as infinity's
it's it's fun yeah it's fun it's cool
it's the natural state it's the natty
state as
frank yang says it's the natty state
yeah yeah yeah
yeah and anything that's not that is
also technically the natty state but
it's also
what's being perfected towards the natty
state
right yeah yes because you don't want to
be
the separate entity that suffers you
want to be
the god state you want to be the
infinite you want to be that
yes absolutely and it's so relaxing the
contraction the energetic contraction
disappears dissolves
that's that's another beautiful thing is
as soon as you do that you feel your
body just
relax you just your shoulders drop you
relax
you're like ah nice
that's just i mean it's yeah right
right right and any
issue you have or whatever social
anxiety depression
it'll just naturally flow away really
if you keep doing abiding in this yes if
you keep doing this
and so it doesn't matter how long it
takes if this is something that's truly
pulling you towards just keep going
yeah that's what it you know yeah
absolutely all of these different wells
another way to view the wadat aloo jude
the unity of all finding
is like all of the different wells these
are the different styles we all dig
these different wells
in different parts of the world but
guess what's at the bottom of every one
of the wells yeah
[ __ ] water yeah yeah right so you
have that water underneath
then you have the wells which i guess
are the people you know the person
consciousness up here
yeah so keep digging and digging and
then you're gonna hit that boom
and then the oceanicness yeah yeah
exactly yeah i love it it's so good
that's cool and so see how analogy is
really the core of cognition
all of these different analogies make it
easy because they're just the different
pointings different ways to point to the
same end
that then make it easier for people to
see it
yes because you're always already
free you're always already the absolute
and yet it remains for you to recognize
it
absolutely yeah that that is another
wonderful point
is you're already there yeah it's like
that awareness of awareness and
even beyond that the infinity is just
yes whatever back here waiting for you
yes yes it's going i'm here
when you're ready exactly and then you
just kind of melt into it exactly that's
a great way to put it yeah
it's the background it's the
undercurrent the background the
undercurrent nissargatsu
maharaj says that the absolute abide as
that which is
behind and beyond all all that is
movable
and transient yeah and so it's the
undercurrent the background like you
said
and it's there always it's it's like
laughing at you
always like why do you keep suffering
come back to me yeah
come back to me yeah exactly yeah yeah
it's just like come on man don't do that
anymore
yeah or do it that's fine but i'll be
here yeah yeah exactly you know yeah
that's great yeah that's so awesome and
the
maya source in many ways can be
described
by source equals awareness
plus maya so at the beginning of this
creative exploration that this is
this specific one what happens is that
awareness is very
low and maya is very high the
intoxication the illusion
is very high then what happens over time
in the creation is awareness increases
and
maya disappears because we become less
intoxicated by the illusion
we become more of gnostic beings we know
our true nature
yes and that's where we're going with
this enlightened civilization as we're
all building towards yes
and so the next creation follows a very
similar pattern
which is awareness starts off and we go
through the rebirths
the nirvana at the some the samkhara and
the nirvana
over and over and over again with our
rebirths until we finally
liberate ourselves from the illusion
from maya yes
and then it doesn't even matter because
nirvana and saskar are the same thing
because what happens is that when you go
into the next creation
you just do the same thing yeah so we're
gonna have to wake up to infinity
the next time we do this right again
yeah right it's not like the end
it's not that yeah i realize infinity
that's it no no no no
it's just the start all you can do once
you've realized it is to serve other
people
there's nothing else you can do yes yeah
and the good thing is
it's naturally serving to other people
it's not like you have to think about
it well you don't think anymore really
you do you think less and less yeah yeah
so it's spontaneous flow and creativity
at that point
yes absolutely another thing that came
up while we were talking about this
was uh i don't know who said this but
the analogy of
tennis tennis yeah i was saying that the
cycle of david if i hit you the ball
i'm not going to run after the ball to
try to hit it back to me
because i want to do that no we're going
to be in flo say and do that
or it's like if you're playing catch
with a dog you throw you know you throw
the ball
you're not going to run after the ball
you're just going to sit back and relax
and it's going to come right back to you
boom so
just visualization analogies really help
yeah
all of these podcast conversations are
tennis you're we're just hitting
the ball back with a creative unique
spontaneous thought around abiding as
awareness and infinity in our true
nature
and then we're just creating the
conversation spontaneously back and
forth
whereas what it used to be like for me
at least
you know five years ago it used to be
much more of a
deeper concern with this person
right i i used to you know wonder
how can i get peace and happiness from
yes everything yes and so that's this
big difference
you become peace and happiness as your
true nature yes
absolutely and it
it heals that too you know if you have
any sort of addiction to whatever
it just kind of breaks that pearl chain
you know it chops it in half every time
you do it it it
and the pearls will start falling off so
yeah you're right because we chase
happiness to begin with with
people places things
but then you know you just keep going
yeah that's great
and you keep going and suffering keeps
acting as the drill sergeant
and you can you can respond to the
feather
it and if you do like warren buffett
says
the eighth wonder of the world is
compound interest
if you respond to the feather you will
gain compound interest because you will
suffer
less but if you wait and don't answer
those knocks from the feather
you will [ __ ] get a sledgehammer
you'll get punched in the face
trust me because the suffering gets
worse yeah me too it's a lot
yeah but it's good it's good
because then it makes you appreciate it
more yeah we designed it
so that maya would punch us in the face
[Laughter]
that's so great that's a great way to
put it we designed it so maya would
punch us in the face
yeah exactly but you know you can look
at however you want it's like
if something triggers you you just go
you know that's just me poking myself
yeah why am i gonna
why do i want to keep irritating myself
or punching myself
yes yes um yes so you realize that from
a higher
you know point of view that's what
you're doing because you want to wake up
to this you want this
you want this this is what you want you
don't want to suffer anymore yes
we've done that for too long yeah
wow okay gorgeous convo that's such a
such a good convo let's wrap on a fun
question let's do
what is most beautiful
what is most beautiful
what's coming up for me this might be
just how my personal experience is
that transformation oh perfect
i could look back five years ten years
and go who the hell
who was that guy who's that guy and you
go
i'm so proud of myself i love myself
this is great yeah and i love everybody
so i don't know the personal
transformation to me what about you
perfect dancer yeah i love you
what a good one
yeah that was great yeah that was
wonderful yeah what a good one
yeah i'll second the answer such a good
one
beautiful wow great timing
love you all we love you thank you so
much for tuning in
we're so grateful very we would love for
you to
leave your thoughts in the comments
below on what we talked about let us
know how you feel
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
like the video support it so that it
gets up in the algorithm
share the video with other people that
you know it would make a profound
influence
on and also check out the links in the
bio below we'll put some of corey's
links in the bio for you to check out
what's a good place for people to check
you out on what platform
i have instagram i have four pictures on
there i'm in my own transformation right
now
i don't have a lot but soon
i'll have some stuff perfect so we'll
put the instagram down there for now
and
abide do it abide shift from the person
to awareness and then make that
impersonal and eternal
and then abide as infinity as void as
source
we love you we adore you thank you